>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
PEOPLE DEBATE ALL THE TIME ABOUT
MASS IMMIGRATION.
WHAT YOU NEVER HEAR ANYBODY DO
IS MAKE THE ECONOMIC CASE FOR
MASS IMMIGRATION.
HERE'S WHY.
OUR COUNTRY'S ECONOMY IS
BECOMING MORE AUTOMATED AND TECH
CENTERED BY THE DAY.
IT'S OBVIOUS WE NEED MORE
SCIENTISTS AND SKILLED
ENGINEERS.
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE GETTING.
WE'RE GETTING PEOPLE WITH WAVES
OF HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATIONS OR
NECESSARY.
NICE PEOPLE.
NOBODY DOUBTS THAT.
BUT FOR ECONOMICS THIS IS
INSANE.
NOBODY TRIES TO DEFEND IT.
INSTEAD, OUR LEADERS DEMAND YOU
SHUT UP AND ACCEPT THIS.
WE HAVE MORAL OBLIGATION TO
ADMIT THE WORLD'S POOR EVEN IF
IT MAKES OUR OWN COUNTRY MORE
POORER AND DIVIDED.
IMMIGRATION IS A FORM OF
ATONEMENT.
PREVIOUS LEADERS COMMITTED
SINCE.
WE HAVE TO PAY FOR THOSE SINCE
BY WELCOMING AN ENDLESS CHAIN OF
MIGRANT CARAVANS.
SOUNDS LIKE A DOPEY SOCIALOLOGY
THOUGHT UP AT LONG BEACH STATE
HALF DRUNK IN THE 70s, YOU'RE
RIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
SOMEHOW THE IMMIGRATION AS
ATONEMENT IDEA HAS BECOME THE
OFFICIAL POSITION OF VIRTUALLY
EVERY GUILTY LIBERAL IN THE
UNITED STATES.
OUR TECH OVER-LORDS, THE ONES
ALWAYS LECTURING YOU, CORPORATE
AMERICA, NANCY PELOSI AND PAUL
RYAN.
THEY ALL BELIEVE THIS.
ANYONE THAT DISAGREES WITH THEM
IS DENOUNCED AS A BIGOT AND
FIRED.
NOBODY BOTHERED TO EXPLAIN THESE
RULES TO THE PEOPLE OF TIJUANA.
TIJUANA IS IN MEXICO, WHICH
MEANS THEY'RE MEXICAN CITIZENS.
BY ACADEMIC DEFINITIONS POPULAR
IN THIS COUNTRY, THEY MUST BE
OPPRESSED.
NOBODY ON THE AMERICAN LEFT
NEVER IMAGINED THEY WOULD HAVE
THE SYMPTOMS OF WHITE PRIVILEGE.
WHEN A CARAVAN OF HONDURANS
SHOWED UP UNINVITED, THAT'S WHAT
THEY DID.
>> THERE'S INCIDENCES HERE IN
TIJUANA AND OTHER PEOPLE COMING
IN ARE COMMITTING CRIMES.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT RACISM OR
BECAUSE THEY'RE FROM ONE COUNTRY
OR ANOTHER.
WE'RE HERE BECAUSE OUR
GOVERNMENT HAS NOT TAKEN CONTROL
OF THESE WHAT WE CALL INVASION.
>> WE HAVE TO BE AWARE OF THESE
PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE BAD PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: SOUNDS LIKE A TRUMP
RALLY.
WHEN DID MEXICAN CITIZENS START
TALKING LIKE THIS?
IT'S CONFUSING.
IT'S LOW PRESSURE DEEPLY
HILARIOUS AND SATISFYING TO
WATCH.
WHAT IS MORE PREDICTABLE IS HOW
LEADERS OF THE CARAVAN ARE
STARTING TO TALK.
SUDDENLY THEY SOUND LIKE
PROFESSORS FROM LONG BEACH.
YESTERDAY A GROUP OF LEADERS OF
THE CARAVAN MARCHED INTO THE
U.S. CONSULATE AND DEMANDED
$50,000 TO RETURN TO THEIR OWN
COUNTRY.
CYNICAL SHAKEDOWN ARTICLES THAT
HAVE BEEN WATCHING TOO MUCH CNN.
WHEN RICH LIBERALS THAT AMERICA
OWES YOU A COMFORTABLE LIFE,
NOBODY SHOULD BE SHOCKED WHEN
YOU BELIEVE THEM.
AND AN ELECTED OFFICIAL FROM
TIJUANA IS NOT A BIGOT OR
SERVING FROM WHITE MASCULINITY.
HE'S A CITIZEN UPSET ABOUT WHAT
IS HAPPENING TO THE CITY HE
LOVES.
HE JOINS US FROM JUST ACROSS THE
BORDER IN TIJUANA.
MR. LOPEZ, THANKS FOR JOINING
US.
WE IN THE UNITED STATES WERE
TOLD THAT THE MIGRANT CARAVAN
WOULD MAKE OUR COUNTRY BETTER,
WOULD IMPROVE AMERICA.
HAS THE MIGRANT CARAVAN MADE
TIJUANA BETTER?
WHAT IS THE EFFECT OF HAVING THE
CARAVAN IN YOUR CITY?
>> THINGS ARE PROBABLY GETTING
WORSE.
WE ISSUED A NEW ULTIMATUM TO
THOSE CAMPING OUT ON THE STREET,
BLOCKING THE STREET AND TRASHING
THE STREET AND WE HAVE A SCHOOL
CLOSE HERE.
THIS IS THE THIRD WEEK AND THEY
WON'T OPEN UNTIL THESE GUYS
LEAVE.
WE ISSUED A NEW ULTIMATUM FOR
THREE DAYS, FRIDAY, SATURDAY AND
SUNDAY.
THEY HAVE TO GO.
SUNDAY THEY WOULD BE REMOVED.
A PRIEST CAME HERE AND HE'S VERY
WELL KNOWN.
HE TALKED WITH THEM AND SAID
THEY SHOULDN'T GO.
THEY SHOULD STAY.
HE WOULD TALK TO THE
AUTHORITIES.
SO SUNDAY THE DIRECTOR OF RELIEF
FOR MEXICO CITY ISSUED AN ORDER
TO STOP AND DON'T REMOVE THEM.
SO THEY'RE STILL HERE.
PROBLEMS ARE STILL GOING ON.
THERE'S LIKE 280 ARRESTS.
BEFORE IT WAS TOTALLY FOR DRUG
POSSESSION AND BEING DRUNK IN
THE STREETS.
NOW IT'S FOR BREAKING AND
ENTERING INTO THE HOMES.
PEOPLE HAVE MADE CITIZENS
ARRESTS.
THINGS ARE NOT NICE HERE.
THE NEIGHBORHOOD IS TIRED OF
THEM, THE MERCHANTS AND THE
SCHOOLS.
>> SO YOU'VE HAD HOME BREAK-INS.
ARE YOU CERTAIN IT WAS MIGRANT
CARAVAN MEMBERS?
>> YEAH.
THERE'S VIDEO.
A MAN SAID THEY'RE FROM
HONDURAS.
>> Tucker: HOW ARE THE POLICE
HANDLING THEM?
>> ALSO WE HAD -- THESE ARE ON
24 HOUR ALERT ON THIS END.
THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT THIS.
WE TONIGHT WANT CRIME RATES TO
GO UP IN MEXICO.
WE'RE TOURIST TOWN.
WE LIVE ON TOURISM AND CHRISTMAS
SEASON IS ONE OF OUR BEST TIMES
FOR TOURISM HEAR AND FOR SALES.
THINGS ARE NOT VERY GOOD RIGHT
NOW.
ALSO, WE DON'T WANT THE MIGRANTS
TO MAKE THE U.S. NERVOUS.
THEY HAVE MARCHES THIS SUNDAY
FROM THE NEW SHELTER.
THEY MADE A MARCH TO THE U.S.
CONSULATE.
THEY DELIVERED TWO LETTERS.
ONE WAS DIRECTED TO PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP.
THEY WERE DEMANDING THAT HE
DIDN'T GIVE THEM -- THEY DIDN'T
GET POLITICAL ASYLUM, HE SHOULD
PAY THEM TO GO BACK HOME,
$50,000.
THEY WERE ALSO DEMANDING THAT HE
SHOULD EXTRADITE PRESIDENT
HERNANDEZ FROM HONDURAS TO THE
UNITED STATES AND REMOVE 13 BIG
MILITARY BASES.
FROM THE UNITED STATES AN
HONDURAS.
>> SO THEY'RE DEMANDING MONEY OR
THEY WON'T LEAVE.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE AN EXTORTION
ATTEMPT.
>> YEAH.
SOUNDS LIKE A RANSOM, YEAH.
YOU WANT THEM TO GO BACK, GIVE
THEM $50,000 TO EACH ONE OF
THEM.
LIKE 700 HAVE BEEN --
>> Tucker: I WAS JUST GOING TO
SAY, POLITICAL LEADERS IN THE
UNITED STATES ENCOURAGED THIS
CARAVAN AND MEDIA FIGURES,
PEOPLE ON TELEVISION IN THIS
COUNTRY ENCOURAGED THE CARAVAN
TO COME NORTH.
NOW THEY'RE IN YOUR CITY.
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO THE
POLITICIANS AND THE MEDIA
FIGURES TO COME TO TIJUANA?
>> TIJUANA IS A GREAT TOWN.
IT OPENS ITS ARMS TO ANYONE THAT
WANTS TO COME HERE IN PEACE.
AND TO LIVE HERE, NO PROBLEM.
IF YOU COME HERE IN A VIOLENT
MOOD, IF YOU COME HERE AGAINST
OUR SOVEREIGNTY, YOU'RE NOT
WELCOME HERE.
WE DON'T WANT THIS PROBLEM.
WE HAVE OUR OWN PROBLEMS AND
WE'RE DEALING WITH THEM.
WE DON'T WANT PROBLEMS FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES TO INVADE US
HERE AND CREATING THIS HAVOC
THAT IS HAPPENING.
>> Tucker: CLOSED SCHOOLS,
PEOPLE IN THE STREETS.
I CAN SEE WHY.
THANKS FOR THAT UPDATE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: IMMIGRATION USED TO
BE CONSIDERED A MATTER OF POLICY
AND PEOPLE DEBATED IT ON THOSE
TERMS.
NOW INCREASINGLY THE QUESTION IS
FRAMED IN THEOLOGICAL TERMS.
ONE OF AMERICA'S GREAT MORAL
LEADERS NANCY PELOSI DOES THAT.
HERE'S AN EXAMPLE.
>> MOST OF US SPEAKING FOR
MYSELF CONSIDER THE WALL